well the u.s. is heading back at France
with proposed tariffs on roughly 2.4
billion dollars of French products
that's after France targeted some of the
biggest American tech companies with its
digital tax album back tax reporter
Laura Davidson joins us now for more
Laura we knew that the u.s. is preparing
a response how does this I guess stack
up in terms of expectations so this
really hits a lot of the things that
Trump said he wanted to hit in response
to this digital tax that you know goes
after Amazon and Google so it's
sparkling wine is on the list you see
cheeses you see makeup you see handbags
China's kind of with porcelain dishes
it's really kind of going after some of
these quintessentially French products
when you look at this also there's not
all that much that the u.s. is able to
import from France but it's a lot of
really iconic products and and and and
goods that Trump for months has teased
that he would want to hit as a way to
respond to France so the probe has been
finished does this mean that we'll get
the tariffs in place or do we have to go
through another process as well there's
there's another process yet to come
there's a comment period where
stakeholders can weigh in and a final
decision will be made that'll be in
early 2020 there'll be some hearings on
that so that that process will move
forward quickly the other thing too is
that the u.s. is also looking at doing
similar probes of Austria Italy and and
Turkey which have also passed laws
having a similar tax to the French tax
so we could see several more rounds of
this several more reports several more
tranches of tariffs in those countries
as well Laurent Davison thank you
Bloomberg tax reporter joining us from
BC come